[Musique]
francis tac
bonjour bonjour ironique merci d'être
sur le plateau de télé fil pour ce gip
que nous consacrons aujourd'hui vous
êtes photographe vous êtes yvelinois car
je crois vous habitez bucs voilà et vous
avez un lien très fort avec les yvelines
car vous avez déjà il ya en 2012 je
crois produits illustrer un livre
six occupants saint-quentin-en-yvelines
que nous voyons à l'écran racontez moi
c'était tout à fait en fait le livre est
sorti en 2013 20 ans après le premier
opus saint quentin en yvelines qui était
sorti en 93 d'accord qui avait été
sollicitée à l'époque par
l'agglomération de saint quentin et
celui ci a été fait en collaboration
avec l'office de tourisme d'accord dont
vous avez photographié toute
l'agglomération
oui enfin bon il ya vingt ans c'était un
peu la découverte de la ville nouvelle
et là bon malgré les évolutions la
l'infrastructure globale n'a pas n'a pas
changé donc nuls est une quatre
nouvelles pour retrouver des différentes
émotions en l'occurrence on voit on voit
ici quelques images mais bon ça prouve
que dans un territoire très proche on en
cherchant on peut trouver des choses
formidables a de la peine mais là on
voit la couleur parce qu'en fait je suis
un gars cool dre édith mois après il ya
eu un autre livre sur saclay oui l'année
suivante on a sorti avec jacques de
givry un livre sur le plateau de saclay
et nauticards là sous la neige en
l'occurrence la s'était laissé la
défense du plateau de saclay et des
intérêts du plateau puisque il est bien
sûr menaces et d'urbanisation we live in
et là ce sont des images afin d
illustrer le livre sont des images qui
ont été faites avec mon paramoteur mon
âme en ulm a déjà donc bah oui parce que
ça fait une petite dizaine d'années
maintenant que je pratique ça d'accord
donc le plateau de saclay par définition
c'est un plateau mais vu du ciel ces
offres
indifférente on a aperçu les étangs de
saclay gelé en hiver et là j'avais
quelques surprises puisque pendant que
je faisais cette image
assandé étant la cd étant de saclay et
enfin bras c'est assez étonnant avec
acculèrent d'autant plus qu'il y avait
un hélicoptère la défense qui menait de
villacoublay qui me survolait à
l'instant faisait ça lui c'était par
hasard la la ça a chauffé un peu parce
que ils ont appelé vigipirate rouge
comme un pilote dans le circuit de piste
que fait-il là etc bref l'histoire s'est
bien terminée
rassurez moi après vous avez aussi
comique de livres sur la bièvre donc sur
la
la maladie absolument des livres qui
sont qui sont forts et qu'ils ont
défendu notre patrimoine local puisque
c'est la même démarche absolument mais à
l'origine c'était pour empêcher la b12
de passer au dessus des sciences de la
vie est vrai de l'étang du moulin renard
a priori ça a bien marché puisque à
l'époque mitterrand habitait rue de
bièvre
évidemment le livre lui avaient été
adressées mais c'est par hasard à
belle-ile
il était allé en se baladant voir la
galerie que jacques de givry avait un
bel hymne qui devait tomber sur les
vivres oil a acquis le libre enfin bon
boulot mais après c'était un autre
combat politique des amis de la vallée
de la bièvre ont gardé intact notre
environnement qui est extraordinaire
d'accord donc vous êtes photographe on
va dire local illinois mais aussi vous
allez aussi au bout du monde vous fait
des voyages à lui sinon dans des
endroits où je demande c'est pas un peu
dangereux d'aller d'ailleurs parce que
vous êtes voyageur photographe on peut
dire vous avez une passion pour le
désert vous avez donc écrit ont dit
écrit quand on est photographe non on
dit quoi écrit ses skis à votre texte
non mais c'est moi qui a porté l'idée en
l'occurrence là y'a pas le robin qui a
complété qui a fait un test un texte
scientifique qui a été relu même pas
regardé par des spécialistes des déserts
et des géologues remarque que le contenu
était
exact en l'occurrence ce livre j'en suis
parti d'une c'est ce livre a été fait en
collaboration aussi avec geoana chat
géographique
c'est un livre qui se donne il s'appelle
planétaire sur sur des espaces de sable
dans le monde c'est pour moi c'est c'est
ma carte firc absolue à d'une c c'est un
bon de l'assurance
donc vous avez eu d'ailleurs le prix
national geographic dans l'occurrence
vais gagner différents prix
deux photos mais bon là ça va ce livre
simplement avait été édité en allemagne
par le national geographic
mais bon ça c'est ainsi une
collaboration
rien de plus très bien ensuite après
d'une taille rouge dr donc tous les
rouges désert alors là c'est un livre
qui qui est plus un livre de
photographies et puis c'est moi qui aie
qui est illustré écrit tout ce qu'il ya
dans ce livre
ca c c'est plus que le prétexte de la
couleur au désert donc à travers non
seulement les paysages mais les gens qui
vivent
je prends l'exemple de la mauritanie où
j'ai toujours été fasciné par par ces
femmes qui sont habillés de tissus
multicolores enfin c'est ça quand on est
patriote au niveau carnet de voyage on a
l'impression que votre
une nouveau but c'est d'aller contre les
idées reçues sur le désert à savoir
montrer la vie dans le désert montrer
des choses qu'on ne soupçonne pas vous
parlez de vous avez des contacts avec
les habitants soient des sédentaires
sont des nomades des chameliers enfin
oui enfin c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
de travail parce que par des positions
en définition des airs évident donc
quand j'avais entamé ce livre d'une
l'idée c'était d'aller photographier les
sables partout dans le monde
oui donc c'était vraiment une quête qui
qui n'en finissait plus et quelques
années plus tard j'avais eu l'occasion
de voyager avec philippe frey
l'aventurier des déserts qu'elle
traverse l sahara de l'est à l'ouest et
on a on a fait une exposition est
commune
atlanta l'alliance française dans un
musée et puis me dit mais présent
présente ça aux éditeurs et tu vas être
pas continuer comme ça enfin donc le
début de dunes c'était c'était une idée
si vous voulez si comme vous dire il
faut tout montrer il faut tout faire
mais c'est vrai qu'il est très exhaustif
mais j'ai continué ma quête des dunes en
l'occurrence quand on parle des des gens
au désert par exemple des caravanes de
sel au milieu du ténéré que ce soit au
niger ou même au mali voire au tchad
c'est un hasard donc la probabilité que
vous trouviez une caravane quand vous
voyagez elle est très faible
c'est ce qui explique un petit peu
comment dire toutes ces images que je
montre c'est des dizaines des dizaines
de voyages oui depuis une vingtaine
d'années les heurts du monde
on y va sans danger un cpa sera festive
la fin je parle de la totale ou en iran
enfin je suis à cheval et globalement
par tout ça ça factuel mans pour
compléter mon dernier projet sur les
oasis j'aimerais le yémen bon c'est à
dire que c'est un peu compliqué en libye
en ce moment c'est difficile vous étiez
à 50 km de la frontière de l'est de la
libye pour jouer mais c'est cette année
j'étais je considère que l'egypte ou
même à jerissa var sont des pays arabes
non extrêmement sûres non mais il suffit
en fait un bond à travers les événements
récents regardez un peu ce qui se passe
en algérie ou en egypte s'est pas c'est
précis enfin vis-à-vis des événements
qui se sont passés en france il ya bien
pas de problème
pays très sécurisé là je reviens je
reviens au mad mel a dû maroc et
l'egypte ont cessé d pays dans lequel
vous sentez en toute sécurité
ota mauritanie je pense que c'est
exactement la même chose l'algérie où il
ya très peu de tourisme
tourisme d'eauze peu d'occidentaux était
et est un pays absolument fascinant j
étais encore à la fin 2000 2016 pour
continuer mon voyage sur les wise as
c'est le dernier opus sur les déserts
que je voudrais dit eh oui vous avez des
images d'oasis qui sont en voie de
disparition pour certaines comme vous
dites sur votre site je crois oui enfin
je suis pas sûr de le dire sur le site
n'a jamais appelé c'est l'objet du
prochain du prochain livre mais je
prends l'exemple de cette image cette
image là c'est une issue à témoin c'est
une quête de 2 10 10 ans pour faire
cette image pourquoi parce que c'est
c'est à l'est de l'algérie
il faut trouver
un moyen un moyen de survoler ces
endroits ces légères en algérie en
l'occurrence ça c'est des photos de
paramoteur mais les occidentaux n'ont
pas le droit de faire du paramoteur en
algérie n'ont donc en l'occurrence et
des stars est un peu compliqué mais ça
vous en faites du paramoteur c'est comme
ça que vous faites vos photos via les
dents parce que je je je me donne
beaucoup de beaucoup de beaucoup de mal
et les moyens nécessaires les moyens
nécessaires talent et le temps les
contacts locaux et des amis qui m'aident
et les sur cette image précédente à
nouveau c'est la photographie des
jardins route
c'est à dire une une une oasis une
palmeraie entonnoir en plein milieu du
désert donc ça consiste si vous voulez à
ce que vos paniers atteignent la nappe
phréatique donc vous creuser le sable
autour des paniers pour que leurs
racines athènes l'eau et ce sable vous
le voulez pour porter sur les bords
alors il ya un des amis localement ayem
qui me disait que son père avec son âne
faisait sans aller retour par jour pour
transporter le sable du centre de deux
durs autres justement à l'extérieur
c'est ce qui crée c'est pour les faire
tout le temps alors vous voyez en
l'occurrence là le cif de delvin est
nocif à dire l'art est vrai qu'il
matérialise ce cet escargot là en
l'occurrence il est il est renforcé par
des
des feuilles de palme donc des paniers
repas sont au fond de la cuvette
ils sont dans la chaleur ils ont l'eau
ils sont protégés du vent
les six en train de disparaître c'est en
train de parler parce que les nappes
phréatiques au sahara ça c'est chou sont
pollués il ya les populations ont fait
augmenter de manière exponentielle ces
oasis et petite oasis sont devenus des
villes enfin c'est un peu la menace qui
peut y avoir en chine il ya longtemps
que les oasis de la veille de la route
de la soie si vous voulez sont devenus
des très grandes villes est offert grâce
et c'est en train de se passer
moi je veux montrer agriculture
traditionnelle dans ces déserts temps
qu'elle existe encore mais il faut
comprendre que des oasis c'est quoi
c'est un dilemme de taille de la surface
des déserts céder quelques endroits où
l'eau affleure d'un accord soit soit en
surface ou à quelques mètres de la
surface on à qui on a trouvé ces
endroits au cours de dizaines de deux
siècles et les gens y ont survécu
le pas pendant des siècles est
dorénavant parole aujourd'hui tout de
suite maintenant si on veut voir
quelques-unes de vos photos elles sont à
la galerie moderne apte à versailles 9
rue du versailles et surtout vous
participez aussi à ce festival de la
gacilly voilà la fiche s'affiche comme
on dit et vous avez participé ou
participent et pardon à la gacilly
car le thème l afrique où est tout à
fait en fait je participe dans le cadre
du collectif qui s'appelle images sans
frontières afin qu'ils représentent des
photographes
du monde entier oui et chaque année on a
une vingtaine d'image qui sont exposées
à la galerie du port à la glace yvon il
ya sept en l'occurrence ça a été ces
photos ont été sélectionnées par cyrille
dos et du figaro magazine
on lui propose une sélection d'image et
j'en ai j'en ai j'en ai fait bien que
donc on va le voir aussi pendant tout
bas donc alain à la guerre il ya
beaucoup de monde et on ne sait pas
c'est pas en descendirent dans le
morbihan entre rennes et vannes à vous
chipotez vos bon d'accord mais on ira
vous voir avec grand plaisir et à
bientôt pour le livre sur les oasis
merci véronique merci francis tac
[Musique]